The third speaker is a black male aged seventeen
at the time of recording on the twenty second of August one thousand
and seventy three interview is
butters it's interesting to note that the speaker
and the following speaker speaking before Ronald
each characterize the other as his best
friend.
The
one we've got a bunch of guys get together
sometimes the say things to each other the kind of insulting.
But they don't really mean it in the comic daimon. You know about that.
Yeah I will say is doing a lot to
me every day.
But we don't know that we see.
So well with it. Oh.
You don't play the game.
It's just. The whole of the board yet
man is don't take
you any she pleased him that he
slapped it but he took me we just
saw that all some of them. Said.
He didn't came and
of course you know and I hope that when the first days you got.
From all
of
them two years ago one
for me
to
come
across the
street.
I want
you
to come here.
We want them to
see
that one
of them just came on.
The
sixty good day what they
don't
celebrate. This
is
now wife.
That's
sure
what is on the sixteenth. Right.
I
thought. I want
to
talk
with
Roger I have.